Luke here with the outdoor Boys YouTube
channel I'm here in the Frozen Alaskan
rainforest and I've brought my hot dad
because it's supposed to be a blizzard
tonight
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
oh that's beautiful
[Music]
what's up
my circle is too small
foreign
oh I had so much trouble getting this
tent up there's almost a three foot
elevation difference from this side to
this side I had to do some funky stuff
to get it to work
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
thank you
there you go got my sled secured so it
won't blow away or get buried
oh
yeah
this wood is covered in ice and is
soaking wet it's going to be really hard
to light so I'm splitting it in the
hopes that it'll burn a little bit
better
just gonna be real careful not drop it
in the snow
oh
Fire's barely going and it's heating up
quite nicely in here making my pants
Steam
that's why everyone calls me hot pants
nobody calls me that
all this wood is wet and cold so we're
gonna put it around the stove to dry it
out before we throw it in I'm going to
string up a little clothesline to start
drying my gloves out
I brought a little luxury item here
laying in that snow was getting my legs
so cold
this is nice
oh
[Music]
you can really feel the temperature
difference out here
uh melting snow is such a pain it'll
probably take me 45 minutes to get this
snow melted and up to a boil
all right we got the water boiling it's
time to make some food
got some beef bouillon cubes a little
bit of salt I got these little lamb
T-Bones here and they're already
seasoned I'm gonna go ahead and cut the
bone out and cut off the grizzle put
that in the pot first
foreign
tea here
oh that herbal tea hits the spot sounds
like the wind's starting to kick up a
little bit occasionally uh Snow's
getting blown off the trees and landing
on the tent it's nice and cozy in here I
got my stew going got a bunch of peanuts
food always Cooks slowly on a hot tent
stove but I'm in no hurry
well the lamb fat is rendering up nicely
so I just added some sweet potatoes and
some tomatoes to the stew
we're gonna add a couple bay leaves I've
got some nutmeg and fennel seed we're
gonna put in there as well
a little white vinegar
all right I'm gonna let that simmer just
got a weather alert on my phone supposed
to be a blizzard warning tonight
we'll see what happens it's gonna be a
lot of snow
we're gonna go ahead and add the lamb
meat at this point add some carrots and
loads of onions
spice things up with some jalapenos
it doesn't smell like burning feathers
in here yeah it does
reaching for a piece of wood and I
brushed against the stove oh that's the
big downside of these hot tents you're
in a very confined space with a very hot
item stuff gets burned all the time
soup's getting close to done so I'm
gonna go ahead and add my garlic and I'm
gonna throw in
green onions
all right just put a little cilantro and
basil in there
a beautiful lamb stew
a little Savory a little sweet a little
bit spicy it's good
oh that was pretty good
that turned out really nice
time for a little dessert
oh
a little cherry pie for dessert warm pie
on a cold day
that was good
I go do some dishes
all right there we go dish is done
now I know a lot of you guys see this
and wonder if that's going to attract
animals animals are not a problem here
there's no animals in these Woods the
reason why the snow's too deep this deep
snow is hard to walk in it buries all
the food any animals that aren't
hibernating they're down in the valley
not up here in the mountains I walked
for almost an hour in this snow and
never saw a single animal print and
that's why you don't have to worry about
animals winter camping in this deep snow
I am soaking wet the inside of the tent
is just wet with condensation every time
I get up and move around I brush up
against the inside of the tent it just
gets me soaked
putting a bunch of kindling before I go
to bed tonight so if I wake up in the
middle of the night and I need a fire
it's not a big ordeal to get some heat
in the tent
oh my socks are so wet I got loads of
snow down my boots today
I'll hang my socks at the top of the
tent they'll dry out pretty quick
so I gotta make sure I don't roll up
against the inside of the tent in the
middle of the night otherwise my bag
will get soaked but if I roll over to
the right too far then I'll hit the
stove and then I'll burn up so you know
I guess it just won't wiggle around much
all right got my hot water bottle with
two liters of boiling water
well it's toasty warm in this bag and I
am tired so I'm gonna hit the sack and
uh we're gonna see what this blizzard
brings because I can hear it snowing
really hard right now we'll see what we
got in the morning
uh good morning
I was woken up by big chunks of snow
falling off the trees onto the tent the
wind's picked up a little bit since
happening a fair amount I think it's
time to get up
[Music]
oh
there's some coals in there
foreign
I better go and put my sleeping bag away
I burned a hole in it last year don't
want to do that again
well for breakfast I'm gonna make
biscuits and gravy
[Music]
I got some hot oil got some pork sausage
gonna add some cream this little bottle
of cream 1600 calories that's why I
don't eat biscuits and gravy every day
putting in some black pepper
and pinch itself now unfortunately I've
messed up a little bit I was supposed to
bring some flour to thicken up the gravy
I forgot
I got some hot dog buns I'm gonna try to
tear them up in little bits and put them
in the gravy to thicken it up sometimes
you can use breadcrumb as a thickener
there we go got it to thicken up a
little bit not bad at all
all right I got this bag of bread dough
that I made up before coming out on this
trip this dough is super simple it's
just bread flour with a dash of yeast
and you add enough water that it's as
wet as it can get without sticking to
your fingers kind of mix it up enough so
that there's no lumps throw it in a bag
and then let it sit for a day overnight
two days you know whatever you want
there we go
flat bread and sausage gravy that's some
good stuff right there
well
[Music]
not a good now obviously homemade
biscuits would be better but this ain't
bad for a guy who slept on the floor
last night
oh that was good that was a lot of food
foreign
every time that wind shakes it dumps all
the condensation down the back of my
neck
back in the dead retreat
oh it's nasty out there that wind's
picking up I think I better get packed
up
[Music]
oh my mittens are all dry
that's a nice treat
[Music]
what a beautiful campsite this right
here is Prince William's sound one of
the most gorgeous Parts of Alaska and
this Forest here is actually rain forest
they get something like 200 inches of
rain every year here
this is one of my favorite places in
Alaska but this storm is getting worse I
think I better get my snowshoes on and
get out of here
there's a good 18 inches of snow on top
of my old tracks from yesterday it's
like I never broke any Trail
thank you
foreign
hopefully I can get it out of the snow
drift
well there you go that's not too buried
I can get that out
oh
my it's a little bit windy out there
there we go you can kind of see the road
thank you
oh how are you is that
straight in the rail stay in the wheel
the drifts are so bad I've got to run
out and Scout ahead
oh that was some sketchy stuff there was
just the smallest window through that
snow drift I had to go and run about 50
feet in front of the car and put my red
shovel in the snow and I'd use that as a
Target to aim for the path and I'd get
there and I'd run back and go another 50
feet and if you got off six inches to
either side you were done but by doing
that me and everybody that was behind me
was able to get through the snow drifts
all right guys we made it to the tunnel
this is the two and a half mile tunnel
that's one lane each lane of traffic
gets one opportunity per hour to go
through the mountain so we just barely
made our tunnel
thank you
oh
hopefully you guys enjoyed this
adventure if you guys want to see more
videos from the outdoor Boys YouTube
channel don't forget to click subscribe
we put out new videos every Saturday
morning I'll see you then
if you like this video don't forget to
check out the outdoor Boys YouTube
channel where we have hundreds of videos
just like this and don't forget to click
subscribe so you can see other great
videos every Saturday morning hit that
Bell button you'll get notifications
thanks for watching
[Music]